we're speaking about hero I've noticed
but none of your character about
pro-social inception are super beings or
super hero but makes you must own
opposite Frank Herbert's dune or many
numbers of judgments of even talking of
course why but don't you like heroes
even if one of your first professional
works was a short story gonna be here oh
yes you don't have a good hero but I
know I've been killing people since my
earliest you know I I grew up on comic
books where we have to the superhero all
concept of the superhero the superheroes
like a professional in Europe you know
with superpowers she puts on a spandex
costume when he goes out in the streets
to to do there were legit
I also edit this series called wild
cards which some of you may know we've
been doing since 1987 it was one guy who
liked it there it's been very popular
and it's about to start being published
in France so I'm excited about that it
was published in Germany and we're about
to reserve it in Germany so and it's
already being published in Italy so it's
pretty pretty popular and it's it's I
got my 40 writers writing for it and
it's a consideration and a whole comic
book idea of Superman hours what
happened what would happen if some
portion of the people in the world got
active superpower is being super strong
or be able to fly or throw lightning
bolts in their covers what would what
would they do and the answer from some
of the best science fiction lines of our
generation may is not buy a spandex
costume and fight the bank robbers you
know if you're like in a cat and one day
you wake up and you the strongest man in
the world then you can lift tanks
overhead and break through
you must be on a really strong
accountants
people people tend to stay with what
they want then the world would create a
celebrity and all that but there's a
long winded way of saying people do
heroic things but very few people are
actually heroes work I get up every
morning and I'm gonna do whatever we
need today I'm going to go out and
rescue someone we think of certain
professions as heroic a cop a
firefighter and these guys are guys who
hold on and can be movin on anytime to
do something too right
they don't do something heroic every day
in fact many policemen go through the
entire lives you know they're 40 years
of the force writing traffic tickets and
they never throw their gone or solve a
murder or save anyone from a farm so I'm
not interested in heroes but music
heroes per se exist in the way that most
efficient sometimes depicts them but I
am interested in heroism and and I think
in the audience like this all of you
have the potential to be heroes like on
Tuesday and then on Wednesday you may be
shits because that's the way we really
mix are we all we all have the capacity
the greater good inside us we all have
the capacity to be selfish or greedy or
petty we've all done things I hope that
we're proud of and if we can admit it
torso we've all done things that were
ashamed of I know I certainly have done
both and that's the many who would mean
that interest me pinpoint what amazing
fascinating creatures human beings are
with all these contradictions inside
ourselves that's the sort of characters
I want to explore not the guy who's just
I am Joe hero world is ultimatum on the
Dark Lord I'm here to bring darkness
over the earth the main character of the
world where Jim could he be a model of
you or some or some kind of hero for you
know haven't uh for you some fascinating
character yeah but he I would call him a
hero is a businessman his season in and
he tries to do his best to help people
but he can get rid of Eddie and annoy
good people too and he's been known to
you know wreck entire cultures and
Ecology's
custom with the noise and something I'm
sure we'd all like to have the power